salut à vous qui êtes peut-être sur la
plage au moment où je vous parle alors
que moi je suis dans la plaie de nuit de
youtube ce maïs sauf que c'est un un
faux décor tout faux soir de tout ça est
complètement fake ce ne sont pas des
vrais immeuble derrière presse avant de
vous donner la nouvelle énigme la
réponse de l'énigme d'hier énigme que je
vous invite à aller voir avant d'écouter
la réponse est oui pour ne pas laisser
les éléments qui ne doivent être pas les
laisser seuls ensemble
il va falloir faire des allers-retours
avec la barque donc dans un premier
temps le lob mais la chèvre dans la
barque traverse et dépose de la chèvre
sur le réglage ensuite il revient à vide
sur l'autre berge et il prend le loup il
prend le loup il traverse email ou sur
l'autre berge et il récupère le lapin
toute la subtilité est là donc ils
laissent le loup tout seul il repart
avec son lapin dans la barque arrivée
sur l'autre rive il dépose le lapin et
il prend le chou il traverse avec son
petit chou il dépose le chou à côté du
loup du renard du renard vient nous
depuis tout à l'heure on parlait bien
d'un renard donc on sait que le renard
d'appaloosa et le chou et apparemment le
chou ne mange pas le renard il repart à
vide et là il va chercher le lapin et
repart avec le lapin voilà la mécanique
qui permettait de faire sa mécanique qui
n'a rien à voir avec les lignes
d'aujourd'hui et les ligues 17 je craque
à linge changeantes énigmes 17 et
surtout et 10 me de logique à un homme
qui est dans sa voiture il suit une
route il est dans la forêt il ya aucun
éclairage sur la route dans le ciel n'y
a pas de lui il n'y a pas des toiles ses
phares de voitures sont éteints une dame
habillée tout en noir de la tête aux
pieds et sur le visage traversé la route
pourtant l'homme freine ralenti la
laisse passer et repart ma question
comment il a pu la voir arriver
vous avez 24 heures pour trouver la
réponse c'est largement assez je suis
quasiment certain vous allez retrouver
des vous avez la réponse
ne mettez pas la réponse dans les
commentaires mais tu es plutôt un pouce
en l'air ce qui nous permettra de voir
le nombre de personnes qui ont trouvé la
solution à l'énigme passé un très bon
dimanche mans c'est quand même vous
abonner avant de partir voire même de
partager une énigme pourquoi il reste
encore 15 pour finir cette série un peu
spéciale sur l'été avec les énigmes et
après le mental blog reprendra son
rythme habituel avec toujours une vidéo
par jour pendant un an
rendez vous demain à 17 heures